هذا هو نوع الخط الذي
نقف في بكين في الخارج لإجراء
اختباراتهم المرغوبة ، يلزم إجراء اختبار مدته 48 ساعة
للوصول إلى معظم الأماكن ، ولكن
لا توجد أماكن كثيرة للذهاب إليها ،
ولا يزال الكثير من بكين مغلقًا.
أحد أشهر الأماكن السياحية
في المدينة ولكن المطاعم مغلقة إلى حد كبير
والمراكز التجارية فارغة جدًا ،
لذا لا يزال مطعم ماكدونالدز مفتوحًا ولكن
للوجبات السريعة فقط ولكن حتى للحصول على الوجبات الجاهزة ،
عليك إثبات أنك خالٍ من
المطاعم  إليك كيف أفعل ذلك ، أفتح
التطبيق الصحي على هاتفي الذكي ، أقوم بمسح
رمز الاستجابة السريعة
[موسيقى] ضوئيًا ،
لذلك يقول إن لدي رمز أخضر
وحصلت على اختبار Cova مؤخرًا ، لذا فأنا على ما
يرام لاستخدام هذا الرمز  تملي كل
حياتنا اليومية في الصين ، فالأخضر يعني أنه من الجيد أن
تتحول إلى اللون الأحمر يعني أنني قد أضطر إلى العزلة في
المنزل أو الذهاب إلى منشأة حجر صحي جماعي ،
وهذا يسمح للصين بتتبع
تحركات جميع 1.4 مليار شخص
تقريبًا باسم تتبع الاتصال I '  لقد حصلت على
مسح الكود الخاص بي للوصول إلى سيارة أجرة أو حديقة عامة
أو مركز تجاري أو ج  حتى في
الحمام العام ، صادفت مجموعة من موظفي
التوصيل في الشارع ، وكان عليهم
إجراء اختبارات شهية كل يوم
للقيام بوظائفهم ، أخبرتني هذه المرأة أن
الوباء كان صعبًا عليها ،
سألتها لماذا تقول إنه  لأنها
تخشى أن يصبح الفيروس مرغوبًا في
الصين على عكس أي مكان آخر في
العالم ، يتم إرسالك أنت وجهات اتصالك المقربين
جميعًا إلى مركز الحجر الصحي ،
وهو مركز مؤتمرات في بكين
تم تحويله إلى منشأة حجر صحي ضخمة
بها آلاف الأسرة ولكن بعضها
من هذه المرافق في البلد ،
فهي في حالة متهالكة للغاية وغير
صحية ، ومن ثم
يمكن أن يتم إغلاق المبنى أو المجتمع بالكامل ، لذلك
نحتاج إلى التحدث إلى رجل كان
في الحجر الصحي وخارجه ست مرات بالفعل
هذا العام فقط أخبرني  ذهب مبناه بالكامل الذي
يضم أكثر من 200 أسرة
إلى منشأة للحجر الصحي الشهر الماضي
لأنهم اعتبروا
جهات اتصال وثيقة ، ويقول إنه ليس خائفًا من أن
يكون مرغوبًا فيه لأن Omicron أقل من سبعة
لقد تم تلقيح وعائلته بأكملها ،
لقد اتصلت بعدد قليل من الأشخاص الذين تم إطلاق سراحهم للتو
من مركز الحجر الصحي الجماعي هذا هنا ،
وسألت عما إذا كانت نتيجة اختبارهم إيجابية
لفيروس كورونا ، نعم ، أومأ الرجل برأسه وقال
إنهم تعافوا ، كم عدد الأيام التي
قضيتها هناك ، سألت سبعة  أيام قال
إن
الاحتجاجات غير المسبوقة اندلعت مؤخرًا في
جميع أنحاء الصين ،
وهم يهتفون بأنهم لا يريدون
اختبارات covid ، إنهم يريدون مجانًا
السلطة
، لكنهم
أخيرًا يخففون من موقفهم بشأن عدم الرغبة في أي شيء ، وتقوم
بعض المدن برفع الإغلاق
وتغيير متطلبات اختبار الطمع
بموجب  بعض الظروف يمكن للناس الآن
الحجر الصحي في المنزل إذا كان لديهم فيروس كورونا ،
وهي صفقة ضخمة ولكن هذا البلد
قد أنشأ بالفعل
بنية تحتية كاملة حول xero covid
وإنفاق جميع موارده على
مرافق الحجر الصحي واختبار فيروس كورونا ،
لذلك سيكون الأمر طويلًا وبطيئًا  الخروج
من صفر كوفيد
أجنبي